the big 5-0 doesn't even look 40. that
is so annoying a youthful 50. happy
birthday to craig council
living the dream a pure wisconsin guy a
pure brewers guy and oh by the way and
this is sixth season as manager has
established himself as one of the best
in the game two balls two strikes cool
has retired the first four brewers he
has faced
and gamble sends one in the air deep to
right field polanco going back and that
is gone a home run
ben gamel we talked about it the first
trip he does it here in the second trip
when the brewers are first on the board
yeah that might have bounced into the
river boy that ball was smoked over
everything out there in the right center
ryan reynolds has hit very well against
the brewers trying to get it going at
the plate this is uh yeah he needs to
need to get it going he's on the verge
of the sophomore jinx here and you see
frustration i mean we saw from moran
getting ejected last night we see it
from reynolds guys that
very seldom have anything wrong with the
plate and reynolds sets one over the
wall for the home run very good he just
loves hitting the brewers
home run number two and just like that
we're tied there's that smile
here's the 01
line toward left reynolds coming on
makes a diving catch brian reynolds what
a play and chad cool an enthusiastic
slap of the mid boy what a catch that
was i mean he needed every inch not only
every inch of his body but every inch of
his glove
as he
just lays out for it oh man what an
effort that's incredible christian
yelich looks toward the sky and says
what do i have to do boy those are some
beautiful clouds oh boy yeah that's
man picture perfect night wish you were
here with us glad you're with us on the
tv side deflected by hauser and thrown
away
bell is in
and the runners move up again the bucks
have the lead a lot of things
going haywire once and deflected off
hauser and the pirates have a lead and
polanco comes through
moran is in pirates lead three to one
i don't know if i'm right or wrong or
about this but i i'd say the fastballs
get hit for a higher average than any
ball
pitch there is no doubt easily so
and tucker beat it out
it's an infield hit
and a run-back of them as reynolds is in
it's 4-1
[Applause]
five straight bucco hits the rally
starts now right let's go with that 4-1
pirates
yelich sends one in the air to left
field he hit it well reynolds going back
at the wall it's gone
opposite field home run christian yelich
and that's how the brewers start the
eighth left that one out over the plate
just enough for christian to get a bat
on it i got two men on and nobody out
got a chance to
tack on here
out of the two-run lead
reynolds strokes one
and this one's gonna head toward the
knots
here comes bella to score moran is
coming in
it's a triple for brian reynolds bucks
have two more
welcome back brian that was nice this
might be the night that he looks back on
and says okay that's when it finally
broke oh it's great to see that swing
back right-handed too i mean
last year when he did have trouble
there toward the end of the right-handed
swing kind of got away from it two
singles run batted in for tucker
and tucker a little pop past that drawn
in infield he has his second rbi tonight
three hits for cole tucker pirates up
seven to two keone keller will come on
got the bottom of the order coming up
well this is not good this is
the last thing you want to see right now
is the medical staff oscar marine
i mean murphy immediately
after a strike call
called timeout and hustled out there he
saw something he didn't like a very
confident face from keaney kelly yeah
that is
and he's a very confident man and just
looking at his face it just give me
goosebumps i
i never like to see that well we've done
a little investigating and you know
trying to wonder what what's going on
now right there he's like that's another
place you want to see a pitcher rubbing
his arm the inside
of the forearm there two and one on the
number nine hitting arcia and out away
from a pirate victory
with a paw cast on it
but hey a win is a win
and these guys
haven't had many to celebrate but
this one was a very convincing
victory tonight well pitched well played
in the field but most of all
the bucks bats got going